des salariés inquiets pour leur avenir
ce matin devant cet hypermarché géant
casino ils sont venus distribuer des
tracts pour protester contre l'ouverture
du magasin le dimanche après midi avec
l'installation de caisses automatiques
il n'y aura donc plus de salariés sur
place uniquement des vigiles pour
assurer la sécurité
ici tous craignent pour leur emploi nous
ce qu'on craint c'est une banalisation
du travail du dimanche a aujourd'hui la
direction met en place cet agent de
sécurité pour assurer la circulation les
clients la convention collective nous
protège du travail du dimanche mais
demain on sait pas si elle nous
protégera vu que ça va être des caisses
automatiques
le dimanche pourquoi ne pas mettre des
caisses automatiques toute la semaine
donc on a un petit peu peur d'être
remplacé
depuis le printemps le groupe a décidé
d'ouvrir progressivement ses magasins le
dimanche après-midi ou même la nuit avec
des caisses automatiques
mais du côté des clients certains
restent sceptiques si on crée un besoin
forcément les gens vont
on l'utilisé mais si si le fin pour moi
il n'y a pas nécessité d'ouvrir le
dimanche après-midi a déjà tellement
d'offres
le reste de la semaine que ça me paraît
superflu si j'en ai le besoin si j'ai
besoin d'aller faire les courses je
dirais même si c'est une caisse
automatique
après je préfère qu'on laisse les gens
travailler c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
créer de l'emploi en automatisant toutes
les toutes les industries
en tant que client oui c'est bien mais
c'est pas bien pour les salariés puisque
on supprime des postes de travail donc
ça va être un peu je pense compliqué
dans les années à venir
nous avons contacté la direction de
casino
on nous expliquer qu'aucun
d'interlocuteurs n'est disponible pour
répondre à nos questions le week end